- In today's video, I'm going
to talk about presentations.
But not how to do and conduct them,
but rather how to
properly prepare for them.
And the inspiration for today's video
was with the conversation
that I recently had
with another former McKinsey colleague.
This person has a leadership position
in a big industry company.
And this person was telling me,
"Heinrich, at my current company,
there are always these
presentations going on.
They almost always start late."
And the main reason for that
is that people do not prepare properly
for this presentation.
And this is a problem.
And this is surely also an area
where I've seen many consultants
with significant mistakes,
which then were perceived
in a very negative way,
both by clients, but often
also your internal leadership,
your partners, or maybe
part of the meeting as well.
So welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel, Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich, and on
my channel I want to help you
to become successful in the
first years of your career.
So without further ado, let's get into it.
I prepared a slide with
a couple of key points
that I will now present to you.
Let's get started.
So now I did prepare a
couple of points for you
on this topic of the right preparation.
And the first point is
really your mindset.
How are you thinking about that?
And here I wanna share two
things, two essential points.
And the first is that you
should make this your problem.
I've seen it so many times
that there were business
analysts, junior conservatives,
maybe interns as part of the team.
And then they left it to the project lead
to figure all these things out.
This is clearly not how it should be.
Now, this is not supposed
to sound too hierarchical,
but at least to me it seems obvious
that you as the junior
person should make sure
that you make these
things your responsibility
to keep this weight off the shoulders
of the more senior person in your team.
Very much related to this
is then the behavior in the
meeting room, in the meeting.
If you actually find out
that something is not working as planned,
not working as expected, then here again,
I've observed it so many times
that there were associates,
junior people, interns in the room,
but then they left it up to the partner
or up to the project lead
to fix certain things
with the technical devices.
This will surely not be perceived well.
If you see that anything
isn't working properly,
you should jump.
You should take responsibility
and make sure that it all works.
Also for the reason
that in the room there
will often be some clients,
some other guests.
Then it would be great for the partner
to be able to entertain these people,
have a cordial conversation with them,
instead of them needing to fix
all the technical devices in the room.
Next is preparation of the room.
And here I trust, we all
already had our experiences
of being in a meeting room,
maybe it was quite a big room
with many, many people present,
but there was only one small microphone
in the middle of the room.
And then people were not
really able to participate.
There was a person sitting
at the other end of the
room saying something,
but this person was not
being heard in the room
because just the microphone configuration
did not allow that.
And this of course is not great.
Especially if you are the
host of such a meeting,
you're inviting a
significant number of people,
always make sure that the room setup
fits the audience that
you're inviting there.
And if you're even somewhere else,
maybe at a building of a client,
you're booking a room and you're out there
and realize it doesn't
work, then look out.
Maybe you'll find a second microphone,
a second microphone device.
Maybe talk with the assistant
of the sponsoring board member.
The assistant might be able to help you.
You might be able to get some devices
out of one of the other meeting rooms
maybe that are close by.
Be there early, look at the setup,
and make sure that the setup
actually suits the needs of your audience.
Related to this point of preparation
is to make sure that you
are dialed in on time.
And again, I've seen it so many times.
You were there shortly before the meeting.
Not everyone is there.
Now it's exactly on time to start it.
And then you realize, "Oh,
we are not even dialed in."
We are not even dialed in
to the video conference yet.
We're not even dialed in to
the telephone conference yet.
Or maybe it was not even clear
whether anybody was
dialing in from outside,
whether all people are sitting
there in the meeting room.
Of course in these
situations, your partner,
your project lead will likely look at you
as the junior person, as the associate,
the expectation will be there
that you will have organized all this.
That you will have this
all top of your mind,
what you need to do to get
everybody in, everybody involved.
And then the last point
is organizing flipcharts,
whiteboards, and similar
pieces of equipment.
So if you're working
for a consulting firm,
for you it's maybe standard
that in every room these
things are present.
But trust me that in many
client organizations,
this is not the case.
So ask yourself what you really need,
what will your meeting rely on?
And if you realize that
you need these things,
either bring them yourself
if the setup allows,
or make sure that via
the personal assistant,
whomever you have at your disposal
to help you with these things
in the client organization,
that you reach out to them and make sure
that it's all set up once you're
there and once you need it.
Next, a couple of points
on what you should probably
always carry with you
as a way a prepared associate,
as a young professional
who is setting up and
conducting meetings like this.
First is adapters for
beamers and monitors.
So nowadays, all people are walking around
with their MacBooks.
You will frequently find yourself in rooms
where there's maybe a beamer
with an old VGA output,
an HDMI cable, any other
of these standards,
and all of (indistinct)
the right interfaces
for your device.
Make sure to always
carry a bunch of adapters
in order to be able to connect
all kinds of different
beamers and monitors,
even if the technology is rather outdated.
Next, the other thing is a presenter.
So something like this.
This is also something
I always have in my bag.
It's a nice and easy device.
You can plug it into every PC,
and then you don't have
to do this little thing
of somebody may be clicking,
advancing the slides on the PC,
and then someone else
presenting something,
and then this is not really in sync.
Maybe then someone is already
advancing to the next slide
where the presenter
is still wanting to talk
about the last slide.
Ah, this is always very cumbersome.
It's so great if you could
just always carry a presenter,
plug it in the device,
give the presenter to your
partner or to your project lead,
whoever is presenting.
And again, this will make
it look as quite organized,
quite well organized if you
always carry these things,
have them with you.
And then at the right moment in time,
you can just drag them out, plug them in,
and it just all works.
Next is always carry with you
some additional spare
audio conferencing devices.
So as a consultant, I was
always carrying with me
a set of two little audio spiders.
So these combination devices
where you have both a
microphone and a speaker.
Because with these you can
easily plug them into your PC.
And then two of them, you can
often combine them, sync them.
And then with two of them,
even in a larger meeting room,
this usually always gave
you enough flexibility
to provide full audio
and microphone coverage
of a larger meeting room.
So here are different brands
offering solutions like that.
I very frequently use the Jabra devices
which I also own myself.
I will link now in the video description
some links to these devices
that I personally use.
So if you're interested in
that, just check them out.
And I also wanna share
some points of advice
on online meetings, online video meetings.
Because of course I very well understand
that many of these physical meetings
are not taking place at the moment.
And here maybe some obvious things.
Of course, make sure that
you're sitting in an area
where you have a stable
internet connection.
And of course, also not too
much noise surrounding you.
And this might sound obvious,
but I still very, very vividly
remember the conversation
of two partners.
And one of my prior employers
where it was not his customer,
the senior consultant should
be promoted to project lead.
And one partner made a
very hard case against that
because this partner had an
experience with this consultant,
but this consultant was conducting
a probably rather important
client conversation
from a train.
He was in an audio
conference from a train.
Due to the of course bad
telephone connection in trains,
he was dropping in and off
of the call all the time.
And this partner was making the point
that apparently this consultant
is not taking the
responsibility seriously enough,
that this consultant should have made sure
that when he is on an
important client call,
that he is not sitting in a train.
That he is making sure that
he has a good connection,
that he can conduct these
calls in a professional manner
as the client will expect
this consultant to.
So frankly, when I heard that,
I thought that this was quite tough,
that only for one incident like that,
your promotion is questioned.
But apparently, obviously, some people,
things like that to some people,
this is extremely important.
So make sure you have these
things in mind as well,
to just not endanger your next promotion,
to not endanger your career as well.
Another point on online video conference
is of course the proper technical setup.
Most people nowadays have laptops
where there's an integrated microphone
and an integrated camera.
And most video conferences
are just conducted
by sitting in front of a laptop,
using exactly these devices.
And I trust this will be the case
for most regular interactions,
most regular conferences.
But especially if you're having
some very important meetings
with very senior people,
consider whether you don't want
to upgrade your equipment a bit.
And here now in my current role,
I had the pleasure to do
the last month's interview.
Lots of people, lots of candidates.
And you would be surprised
how many of these people were
sitting in dark environments.
You could barely properly see them
due to the low quality camera
that they used in the laptop.
Maybe there were also noise interferences.
The audio was not very clear.
Of course this will not help
you to make a great impression.
So think about that.
Don't you have one,
two, 300 euro to spare,
to invest in a proper microphone
and some basic lights?
Maybe even an external
camera to properly make sure
that you have a nice picture.
With a couple of hundred
bucks, you will be able
to significantly improve your
video conferencing setup.
And this might be very
much worth the investment,
especially for facing
these types of situations
that are now highlighted.
Now, in one effort to
combine all of these points,
I think that there's
one common denominator
that really, really defines
whether you are able to prepare yourself
in the right way or not.
Because the truth is even
if you're 10 minutes early,
10 minutes in the room
before the meeting starts,
this will usually barely be enough
to connect all your devices
to the other devices.
This will be barely
enough preparation time
to make sure everything is
set up and works properly.
But as soon as you have
one little problem,
as soon as one thing does
not work as expected,
usually you will run out of time
and you will not be able to
start the meeting on time.
From my experience, especially
for important meetings
where you want to make sure
that everything works smoothly,
you should be in the meeting room
at least 30 minutes before the
meeting starts to make sure,
to give you enough time,
to set everything up,
and to have this fallback option
that if something is not working properly,
that you at least have a chance
to find maybe a replacement device,
to maybe get an additional
microphone from somewhere,
to potentially call a
technical support person
that often many client organizations have.
If you are not in the room 30 minutes
before the meeting starts,
you will not be able to do this on time.
So as with most other
things in life as well,
good preparation is key.
Be sure that you behave as a professional,
especially if you're working
in professional services.
And a big part of that
certainly is to make sure
that you prepare for
your important meetings
in a very meticulous and diligent way.
And of course,
I do hope that this video
contained a couple of tips
which will help you to do exactly that.
But now I would love to hear from you.
Do you have even more advice
on this topic to share
that might be beneficial
to other members of the Firm
Learning community as well?
I would very much appreciate
to see comments from you.
And of course, as you know,
every comment also helps
with the YouTube algorithm.
So if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the Like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe to the channel
to stay up to date on all my content.
I'm releasing new videos
every single Saturday
here on my channel.
And if you want to see even more from me,
I'm also present on other
channels such as Instagram,
Tik Tok, or Twitch.
And I also have a mailing list.
You'll find the links to all these medias
below in the video description.
And if you would like to learn more
about how to create presentations
in the style of leading consulting firms,
I once created a fully
fledged online course
exactly on the topic.
Again, a link to that in the
video description as well.
And I also wanna say thank you
to all the members of Firm Learning.
You're really making a great
contribution to the channel.
This is much appreciated.
And if you want to join as well,
just hit the Join button
next to the Subscribe button.
So if you want to continue
your learning journey
with this channel,
there will be more videos
appearing next to me.
So feel free to check them out.
Again, I release videos
every single Saturday.
So see you again next week.
Until then, good weekend to all of you.
This is Heinrich from
Firm Learning. Bye-bye.